all right you bastards we're gonna be
playing what the [ __ ] away game plan out
we're gonna be playing yeah sure why not
um when I convoy decoy to us
we need to be careful Pierce oh yeah
place might be compromised we should get
some horses and mount a charge on stack
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] going on with Aires
he's he's going he's going brother crazy
um there's a thing that I heard that
you're like yeah this has nothing to do
with race but if you're a brother so
whether you buy my creation if you get
too much into the brother miss you get
something called brother edema
it's like swelling in the brain just
being too much like brother that brain
ages too fast you just get kind of
[ __ ] up so yeah that [ __ ] let's go
down here
gather the science headquarters
oh he's [ __ ] down here on a [ __ ]
here today uh you're on the phone on my
time over my dead body [ __ ] that guy
anyway back to the gameplay I'm at the
headquarters not maybe gonna head out
decided my fat [ __ ] got a garage hey
what the [ __ ] is going on here I can't
hack it I see the issue here now there's
only one issue here
Cat Cat Cat
pack it up we got to move
I got 20k on this game oh this isn't
over
so it's not safe here you guys clear
this place out I'll buy you some time
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] going on here sounds good
I'll phone one of the stag bases and
drama way I'm good good good that Kenny
stag race it gets the stag base and
cause some [ __ ] higher okay okay shut
up ah [ __ ] about some people with me
better [ __ ] you know you only live once
oh oh here's a big day here [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] only take what's
important the chessboard doesn't count
chef Zach that's right I got got
sure okay got good cut cut
Alvin case - yeah sure
revived time where yeah I got I got no
[ __ ] money okay is that nice man oh
come on come on [ __ ] uh sorry it's a
two-seater car yeah it's okay I'll
follow
what's the best thing these guys have
well there's a lot of nice [ __ ] get in
here
current ventures come on
[ __ ] is going on here
I'll let you know how the street saw it
again how do I know I gotta get back in
there
these aren't indestructible
what the [ __ ] is going on to switch this
plane out okay it's five carry stock
okay they're just let's just do this
wait why is all the [ __ ] like inside
stuff this is this is frankly this is
how to accept them
okay there's a car we go to [ __ ]
years
oh okay got him bet she has get it get
it how hard is the [ __ ] get britches
all right I just I just run into them
but I can
this chefs taking a tail on my chop
that's
oh sure
all right the [ __ ]
sure thing dog [ __ ] I need the crusader
where is it where is it should be around
here somewhere
that guy got one where the [ __ ] is they
there's the Crusader I just [ __ ]
ordered one
how come this is like no damage okay
yeah that doesn't [ __ ] nothing
what the [ __ ] is up with this look it's
inside the box
okay where the [ __ ] is the vehicle
delivery I care about here a little bit
just done it's like stuck over here or
something you know
come on that's [ __ ]
I can't I figure out what the [ __ ] to do
here I [ __ ] hit it with this thing
hmmm how this was working thanks for the
help dismiss this party rid of me
already
okay let me try this
I is not working [ __ ]
Oh Chet I think I might have pissed them
off you're probably airway gasps now
I'll let you know how the streets are
okay
do the Saints proud
he says okay anyways I can go man I
don't know if I I don't even know if I'm
gonna [ __ ] it at that other [ __ ] out it
was [ __ ] terrible
they like to list horribly I was like
doing random [ __ ] like ten hours
they'll keep in the street side you've
got to pick it up with you shut the [ __ ]
up
go back to your little game well okay
killing looks like dad left roadblock
ahead of us without help wait shut the
[ __ ] up [ __ ] shut the [ __ ] up
focus fire on that beetle until another
target is located
yeah all right good to go now
okay score more planes huh yes that
isn't a good thing
reinforcements are rolling out
finest a great again why are you saying
there's like [ __ ] you okay let's go
that's how
and I'm like but the white version of
bring that be told down that's yeah okay
yeah
okay
shut this [ __ ] has got a low dancing
that looks so cool look at my tie better
look at my face my face
[ __ ] this is getting like in sand
my [ __ ] King and I claimed it pretty
well up
let's do this [ __ ] luckily I can turn
into our fish well
oh [ __ ] outside out
catgut gun
let's see how the fish feels about that
I am sneaking look at me a dangerous
fish
okay that set
ah great
Jesus
okay sorry guys if I forgot to I cut the
sign out so I had to flip my ham steak
that graceless belting up this little
grace fired
shut the [ __ ] up [ __ ]
you know like you've got to pick it up
with their air convoy Delta Delta one
and drink steel Porter's faith
that's a Renault leg you got the cleanup
yes thank you
so you're already there right it's a
sound it's just for you
so faster would be better got it what is
that
can I just take a ram into it that's a
huge [ __ ] plane though
focus fire on that VTOL until another
target is located
[ __ ] it's a big plane
okay guys good
why are they are they
I'm gonna fly straight into this [ __ ]
see what I did was that week in it and
then I just fought yeah I'm into that
[ __ ] like that
laughs elevates up come on let me hit it
let me hit it hit it got ya I'm Joshua
Burke hey on TV I play Knight blade an
exceptionally good-looking but
misunderstood vampire who risks life and
limb every week to keep the world safe
huh the men and women of stags put their
lives on the line every day to protect
your city oh yes gang violence want to
be a real world hero talk to your stag
recruiter today I know I have I guess so
clean stack why don't you just put
someone in a [ __ ] deer suit shock and
awe winds worsen authorized the Daedalus
and this will all be over
absolutely no that kid's gonna get
himself killed by someone who can
understand yes ma'am
thank God thank sriracha guys thank ya
sticks out for Harambee